nearly three months after it was sealed
off from the world
Wuhan has opened its doors again
highways and train lines have been
opened to traffic and it's 11 million
residents are now able to leave without
specific authorization but they still
need an app that tracks their health and
movement government figures show the
vast majorities of China's coronavirus
related deaths were in Hubei Province
where the city of Wuhan is located well
Katrina you now joins us live from
Beijing Katrina it's now been 76 days
since Wuhan residents were allowed to
leave have we seen a bit of an exodus
today quite an exodus we know tens of
thousands of people had been heading to
airports train stations and bus stations
to leave Wuhan more than 50,000 people
bought train tickets ahead of today and
more than six thousand are expected to
get on flights heading out of Wuhan
people are so taking advantage of open
borders finally getting into their cars
and also driving outside of the city
were seeing roads and highways clogged
for the first time traffic in the city
since the outbreak began now since the
lockdown began at the end of January the
transit hubs were the first to close so
11 million residents found themselves
sealed off from the rest of the country
indeed the world and not only residents
of Wuhan but also workers and families
who had traveled to the city for Chinese
New Year expecting to be there for only
a few days and 76 days later they were
still stuck there so many people are
relieved to finally leave her to finally
have that freedom but not everyone in
Wuhan does there are still some people
who are still confined to their homes
because there are still active Kovach 19
cases identified in their neighborhood
and if that is the case they're still
not allowed freedom of movement but for
the most part especially in virus free
areas of the city restaurants are open
malls are open the subway has been
operating for a few days now and as long
as people are wearing a mask they can
have their temperature checked and as
long as they have a mobile phone app
which shows a green barcode declare
that they are healthy they're able to
come and go with relative ease mm-hmm
Katrina can you tell us a little more
about how this app works I mean how do
they decide if you actually get that
little green barcode do you have to see
a doctor first don't necessarily have to
see a doctor now this would all relies
on China's big data surveillance system
so you first have to download an app
into your phone and input your details
and the main information I think really
is your address and your address will
tell the proximity to a confirmed case
and based on that proximity you will be
either given a red bar code which says
you are at risk for your unhealthy a
yellow code or a green code and the
green code means you're healthy and
you're relatively free to travel around
so let me just show you what that green
code looks like so it's green and it has
a QR code and this is extremely
important in Wuhan City and you cannot
go anywhere without it
what you must do if you go into a bus
for example if you go into a taxi if you
go into a convenience store or a
restaurant you present this green code
and it's scanned by a machine in any of
those places and what that does it
registers your presence there in that
shop restaurant or train carriage for
example and what that means is later
down the track authorities identify that
there has been somebody with koban 19
there in that train carriage with you
they will then automatically have all
the data of all the people who were with
you that day and they will track you
down and also put you under testing or
into quarantine so that's how that works
and in Wuhan and a smaller level of that
is also working around China in Beijing
for example if I go into a shopping
center I need to scan a barcode it will
have and it will check according to my
phone data if I have been outside of
Beijing and if I've been outside of
Beijing it will show them and I won't be
able to enter that premise for example
Katrina I mean more broadly in China
we've also been seeing these very low
numbers of deaths over the last few days
but the numbers there have obviously
been questioned since the very beginning
of this outbreak so as we see
restrictions now being eased how
confident can the world be that China
does have things under control
well there seems to be a downward trend
I mean we've had single-digit figures in
terms of deaths and and local
transmissions of new cases for a few
weeks now the government has old but
declared victory saying the peak of the
outbreak is well and truly over
they're quite keen of course to get the
economy going and at the same time that
is the caveat these are official figures
and there is a lot of skepticism because
these numbers are much lower than other
countries say the US or many European
countries so people are raising
questions as as to whether these are
accurate and if indeed it is that safe
to go out and commence normal life as
has been happening here in China but I
think what the key thing to look at is
really that even though these numbers
may not be exact
the downward trend does seem to be true
just evidence by I guess the confidence
of the government in easing these
restrictions I think China and the
Chinese government and they're very
risk-averse
especially those living in Beijing the
last thing that they do want to see is a
second wave of infections they don't
want to risk that anymore and the fact
that these Wuhan borders are easing the
fact that people are returning to normal
life that certainly seems to signal at
least that China's leaders do genuinely
believe that it's safe enough to get
people going back to work but of course
as you said the numbers are still they
do seem very positive I think 1,000
people are out currently undergoing
treatment for over 19 in the past 24
hours
62 new cases but only two of those new
cases of two or three of those were
local transmissions 59 were actually
imported cases of Chinese nationals
bringing the infection into the country
foreign nationals are still banned and
even local travelers do still have to go
under undergo strict testing and strict
quarantine when they arrive into a new
city so they are still very much keeping
an eye on the outbreak here
Katrine are you there for us in the
Chinese capital thanks very much for
that update Katrina